العديد من اللاعبين حرمتهم الاصابه من
اللعب في كاس العالم او اقبال البطوله بعد
بدايتهم فيها حيث حرمه الاصابه لاعبي
المنتخب السعودي ياسر الشهراني وسلمان
الفرج من اكمال المونديال بعد المباراه
الاولى الملحميه مع الارجنتين كذلك حرم
المنتخب البرازيلي من مجهودات لاعبي نيمار
دا سيلفا وغابريال كاسيوس والك بعد
اصابتهم خلال دور المجموعات المنتخب
الارجنتيني خسران مجهودات لاعبه دماريا في
مباراه دور 16 امام استراليا سبب الاصابه
وفقد لاعبه جيوفاني لوسيلو بعد بدايه
اما المنتخب الفرنسي كان اكبر الخاسرين في
المونديال حيث خسر كريم بنزيما قبل ايام
من انطلاق الحدث العالمي وكان قبلها قد
خسر مجهودات لاعبه بومبا
فيما خسر منتخب السنغال نجمه الاول ساديو
ماني من البطوله بعد اصابه عضليه تعرض لها
قبل كاس العالم بايام
[موسيقى]